yes we failed we failed conservatives
totally failed on this because
what the left is offering a vision of
society
it basically the left the radical left's
vision of society is just
the the inverse of whatever the vision
used to be you know in the 1950s if you
were a communist you would be canceled
you would lose your career in hollywood
you you could be prosecuted i mean it
was it was illegal under the smith act
uh today you'll be canceled if you're an
anti-communist right so it's just you'll
still be canceled but it's just the
the total flip of it but they're
actually putting forward that vision of
society
what is the conservative vision on this
the conservative vision is to defend now
and this is only over the last 20 years
or so
to defend free speech in the abstract
right or to defend freedom of belief in
the abs it's always in the abstract
but they won't ever get down to the
brass tacks of
what should we say what do we believe
what is our
what are we offering people other than
nothing and it's this is why on the
occasions that republicans have won
elections in in the last 20 years
all we've ever managed to do almost
without exception
is cut taxes a little bit and maybe cut
regulation a little bit but actually
maybe not
and that's it and and so the i guess the
question you have to ask yourself is
after
after the reagan revolution and even the
trump revolution and the gingrich
revolution we want to won all these
elections
would you say the country today is more
conservative
more free than it was 20 years ago
no way
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host
of the aptly titled michael knowles show
on the daily wire and the author
of the brand new book speechless
controlling words
controlling minds michael knowles
welcome back to the reuben report
dave thank you for having me it's good
to be with you i felt my intro there was
very
professional broadcastery because you're
a professional broadcaster and i felt
that you enunciate
very well and you with the posture and
the whole thing how'd i do there
i was very impressed and look the whole
book is about words
your addiction your articulation
beautiful beautiful all right let's get
the stuff we got to get out of the way
right up top uh
you screwed me everybody knows you
screwed me it's been talked about many
times
i'm brought on other shows they asked me
about it uh yeah
we were having drinks uh last spring
you were at my house with your lovely
wife and we were drinking whiskey and
eating steak
and we decided in a drunken stupor that
we were both going to stay and fight in
los angeles and dethrone
gavin newsom and keep the union together
and it was very exciting and then i
couldn't wait morning
it was announced that you were moving to
nashville well yes
that uh was now in in my defense dave
i was very excited i was filled with
pure vitriol against gavin nussolini
i we had imbibed quite a bit we were in
your beautiful
home oh we were ready to go then i walk
in
and you know what happens here at the
daily wire they i walk into the room you
know what
they say jump and you know what i say
dave how high
that's what i how high and i jumped so
far that i'm in tennessee
you are in tennessee i saw you you're
settling in how's it going for the daily
wire in tennessee are you guys happier
now that you've
left los angeles left me left dennis
prager
and the one other decent person in this
craptastic town
it's got there's got to be one i'm sure
there's well uh gary cities
gary yes gary sinise would be there
corolla
no see there are some there are some
people left but it's true a ton of
people are fleeing and they're fleeing
to three places
tennessee texas and florida florida now
is like
truly the last bastion if it's just
gonna break off and float into the
atlantic ocean
it's great my little newborn son who was
he was born here
he's going to have a little southern
drawl the first knolls probably ever to
have one
it's good i i have guns i have money
i breathe the sweet air of freedom
people are nice and normal here
it's it's it turns out that the that
little part of america the little part
between new york and l.a you know you
might have heard of it
it's actually a pretty nice place you
mean we shouldn't just think of it as
flyover country there's actually some
decent people there and decent customs
and
no you can land a plane actually it's
not you can actually land it here and
there's like stuff to do and people and
it's
nice yeah they're just absolutely
incredible do you think
i mean now that you know some time has
gone by almost a year
actually since we had that conversation
at my house do you think i'm bananas i
mean what do you think of the remaining
people who are trying to
keep you know these states not from
going into complete progressive ludicry
although
maybe it's done already i don't know i i
think you are bananas i know
the kind of the formal excuse for this
sit down was that we were going to talk
about the book or whatever
this dave this is an intervention
your friends love you very much we want
to see you happy we don't want to see
you
hurting yourself and every minute that
you
stay in that hellscape in california
you it that is you're inflicting harm on
yourself
and on society you got to get out you
got to come to the sweet land of freedom
plus you had fried baloney there which
was really something
not just the the air and the money and
whatever else you said it was also the
probability all right before we get to
the book let's just
do a little recap of what's going on in
the world because i haven't we haven't
sat down together in a while it's been
well i did your show when i was in
nashville a few weeks ago
we got we got drunk in the middle of the
day that was fun uh but the last time we
sat down was
uh when i came back on the grid and you
you welcomed me back
so a lot has happened obviously the
world is just completely bananas what
what what's your grade if you have to
grade the state of
the world right now what are you feeling
uh
well i think it resists letters i think
we've if we're doing a through f we no
no we and we go down to z
no and you try the greek alphabet
they're renaming all the covid variants
it's no longer the indian variant or
whatever that's politically incorrect
so now it's they're using greek letters
like omega and
pi and they're saying that's much
simpler it it even goes beyond the greek
alphabet what is happening right now is
we're seeing an
inversion of reality right we're seeing
we we all kind of had a basic
understanding of the world
and we all you know we squibbled over
whatever but we that now is been
completely turned up upside its head and
i i think actually the the great example
of this
is the in it's why everyone's talking
about this gender issue
it is the insistence that we must
go along with this ideology that says a
man is a woman and a woman is a man it's
it's only one minor issue but it's a
symbol of the broader problem and
we are told by the doctor fouches of the
world
these people who have no accountability
to the people whatsoever that if we
question what they want us to do that
changes every single day in political
calculations
that we are anti-science and
anti-democracy
they'll say if we the people question
what these totally unaccountable elites
do
in contravention of the laws that we are
threatening our democracy and i i often
think of
angelo codevilla who's the scholar at
the claremont institute who pointed out
that whenever they refer to our
democracy
what they really mean is their oligarchy
it's totally
totally the opposite so we're we are
just in the upside down right i know i
can drop a star wars reference with you
but it was only a few weeks ago that
fauci said if you're against him you're
against science which is very palpatine
i am the senate
you know it is i always i always assumed
i thought i thought palpatine would be
like joe lieberman or so you know they
kind of bear that physical resemblance
no it's tony fauci that's the man
the lockdowns you you were pretty much
against all of it from the beginning
right like you were i'll give cred i'll
give credit where it was due
you were pretty much against all of this
from beat one was there did you have a
little window
what were you doing in that two week to
flatten the curve thing no i i had no
window i mean i i've been licking
doorknobs
since this virus was announced uh i was
willing to entertain the idea
that the government has sort of
emergency powers during a pandemic so
when they said
two weeks to slow the spread i i said
this is a bad idea i don't like it i'm
against the masks i'm against all of it
but it is within our political tradition
for certain governments and ideally more
local governments to take these kinds of
actions
but the problem with it and i knew it
from the top and i think you know it and
a lot of us knew it
is it was never what they said it was
they said that it was about two weeks to
flatten the curve we knew the minute you
give them this kind of power it's not
going to be two weeks
tonight it's not gonna be 15 days it's
not going to be 15 months it's still
going on right now
they said that the reason we need to
wear the masks well sorry
after they told us not to wear the masks
when they told us we had to wear the
masks
they told us the reason for that is it
will help us get back to normal
but but i knew as i think anyone with
common sense do
the masks not only won't help us get
back to normal it will they will ensure
that we never get back to normal
because when you see someone wearing a
mask that symbol does not tell you
oh good everything's normal again that
that thing we've never
been in a culture where everyone is
covering their face and muscling
themselves
that tells us we are living in
extraordinary and extraordinarily
dangerous times
and ever all the normal rules of
engagement have to be suspended
and that has continued there are still
people wearing those muscles today
isn't it interesting how they at first
were saying oh we'll get
back to normal meaning two weeks to flat
occur then we'll get back to normal but
then it did shift
a certain amount of months in it shifted
to no there's a new normal
those are very very different things
they they told us there's a new normal
and i asked scientists even scientists
who are broadly
more conservative you know who are more
in the center
and i said so what's up with these masks
is this ever going away
and i kid you not some of them told me
well michael look
yes it'll go away as a permanent measure
but you know maybe every flu season the
masks come back i mean mike
it's really crazy before before we were
so crazy
we shook hands with people oh that's we
can't return to that
we didn't wear masks on airplane i mean
you know so some of that is just that's
the way we're going to live now and i
thought
you you people have lost your minds
have we watched just a complete collapse
of
well i think all of our institutional
elite and all that i think you're you're
in agreement with me on that in our
educational lean baba but just sort of
like
the average guy that used to be somewhat
sensible like where is everybody
that's what i every day i'm like just
where is everybody i guess they're just
locked up at home
they're locked up at home and they're
they're quite afraid and
this is what was so brilliant about the
political strategy of of the masks and
the lockdowns and
don't forget we talk about how it was a
scientific strategy public health
officials are part scientists and part
public
politician the health part is the
science and the public part is the
politics public and politics are
synonyms and as a political strategy
it's very difficult for for people to
organize and oppose the ruling power
if they're not even allowed to gather
right you mean
you were not permitted to see anyone
outside of your home so they isolated
everybody
then when you could go in public you had
to wear this sort of secular kefia
you know this kind of a modernist burka
where you're covering your face
yeah just wait until they get rid of the
secular part that's coming next
i don't want to freak everybody out
that's on the heels but then
even you say okay well i'm not allowed
to gather physically i'm not allowed to
see my friends
well at least we can we can correspond
online right
no you can in in the heat of the 2020
election which is what all of this was
about
let's let's not kid ourselves in the
heat of the 2020 election
if you found an article on the new york
post that had
very pertinent information about the
election you couldn't message your
friends
the function to direct message someone
to send a message on facebook
that was shut down that was disabled if
you said something
that the regime did not approve of
namely if you pointed out that
hunter biden had all of this evidence of
illicit activities that also
may or may not have implicated his
father so they alienate us physically
they alienate us digitally
is it any wonder that the the
conservatives are having a hard time
coming back to common sense
and is it any wonder watch this segway
that we've all become
speechless you see what i did there
professionally i've been doing this a
little older than you know
a little older a little older though you
are professional all right let's talk
about the book
uh you did you screwed me again because
uh you know you left l.a
then you email me or you text me a few
months back
dave dave i'd love to put you on the
back of the book
can i get a blurb i'm going to send you
the manuscript read it if you like it
say something nice about me and i said
something nice about you and i don't
have the book yet it's end root but i do
have
we printed it out okay we printed it out
i have the full book
i have part of it right here uh
apparently i did not make the back cover
so now look in my defense dave i i am
but a lowly writer
now i send these things in and i say
okay here are these blurbs
and the publishers they were very
excited about your blurb it's in it's in
there it's in the book then i look at
the back cover
you got beaten out of the cover by
shapiro
you got beaten clavin andrew clavin they
put i know it's outrageous
this is you might say it's a sort of
digital book burning
of your of your quote which is very
relevant
it is to your body of work all right all
right let's not make it about me i did
make it into the front of the book so
it's okay okay speechless look
you put words in a book this is this is
something new for you
uh your last book obviously reasons to
vote for democrats you didn't put any
words in
no words very clever by the way probably
the greatest money-making scheme in
literature history but how was it how
did you like the writing of a book
that you were going to it was it was
terri i'd actually like to quote
at length your blurb i want i want
people to know that dave read this
this is this is this is the only nice
thing you're ever going to say about me
michael knowles has been one of
america's most fearless and important
political thinkers in a time of
unparalleled censorship
the fact that he put actual words in his
book is proof of that and i will tell
you dave
i'm never going to make that mistake
again because it's so
much time oh my gosh i wrote my first
book in about three minutes
and that was only because i couldn't
figure out how to format the the
little bottom where i put the page
numbers you know and this thing took
a long time to write it took a long time
to research and it actually
did change some of my ideas i went in
and i knew i wanted to write a book i
felt there was not
really an a very accessible history
of political correctness which now we
also call wokeness or cancer culture
and i said okay i just want to write
that i'm curious for my own sake
how did we get here because the harder
we fight against political correctness
or wokism or whatever you want to call
it it seems the more ground we lose
so why is that and i went into the book
with this preconception that
conservatives and classical liberals
i would you know lump together in this
understand free speech
and censorship much better than the
radical left does
and i i was quickly disabused of this
notion
i actually think now if you take these
radical leftist
theorists seriously the people who you
can trace it step by step
the people who gave us this current
cultural mania
i think they understand speech and
censorship
much better than we do i think that's
how they are so much more successful
at shaping it than we are and i think we
ignore that to our own peril
so i like the part of the book where you
mentioned just that and that's actually
where i was going to start with my
i've got highlights too the idea
basically that they're willing to use
structures of power to do things that
those of us
let's say on this new right are not
necessarily willing
to use this is where you will always say
to people i always see you saying on
twitter to people well i'm not a
libertarian and i do occasionally
want to use some power can you can you
talk about that a little bit
yes because you'll always hear this
response whenever you say that we should
have standards at all or you know that
that
drag queen story hours shouldn't be able
to twerk for toddlers and you say maybe
this isn't the greatest thing in public
libraries they'll say well i thought you
were for small government
and i say i'm i'm not for small
government i'm for limited government
but i'm not first there's no such thing
as small government in a country of 330
million people that has
overseas holdings in the pacific okay
there's no such thing that goes from
puerto rico to
guam right that's you can't have a very
small government but you can have a
limited government that is within
its own just power and
moreover when on the rare occasion that
republicans are given power by the
people through our constitutional system
when we get that power republicans seem
totally unwilling
to wield it they seem to think that any
use of political power is somehow
unjust and i think part of it is
because we we have made a big error
and and it's something that the founding
fathers were very precise about and
really all great statesmen are which is
we have conflated liberty
and licentiousness we have conflated the
right to do what we ought to do
with just being able to do whatever you
want at any given time
and the example i give of this is the
heroin addict
right according to the real definition
of liberty
the heroin addict is not a free man
according to the modern liberal
definition of liberty he's the freest
man in the world right he's got a couple
bucks in his pocket he can shoot up
whenever he wants
but we know he's not he's a slave to
these really base
appetites he does i don't think he
really wants to shoot up the heroin in
terms of his
his higher rational will and so we
conflated those two things
and we we kind of gave away the game
the fact is all societies are going to
have standards
okay all societies are going to say that
you can say some things
and you can't say other things and we've
got a great speech tradition in america
but from the very beginning there are
whole swaths of speech that you are not
allowed to engage in fraud
sedition uh uh fighting words direct
threats obscenity those things have been
illegal for the whole history of our
country
and for good reason because those things
that if you
protect that with free speech they
actually undermine free speech
if you protect fraud then nobody can
trust anything anybody says
if you protect obscenity to a large
degree
people are going to just become you know
roiling
sex machines that aren't aren't thinking
very well which i guess is
one the name of my high school band and
two the kind of way that we've become in
the society
so i just think the left understands
there's always got to be some limit
and they've used it they've totally
transformed those limits to their
advantage
and meanwhile what do we do we throw up
our hands
and it's actually it's even worse than
that there are two ways that we respond
to this
generally as conservatives or
libertarians the one is you got the
squishy types
the squishies just they go along
whatever the new rule is they just go
along with it
but then just as bad or are the stubborn
you know
my freedom my conservative types who
they say i'm not going to go along with
the new standards i'm going to get rid
of standards
all together you know say totally
absolutely whatever you want do
absolutely whatever you want what
what i think they fail to realize is the
whole point of political correctness
is to destroy the old standards the
whole point is to destroy the
old way of life as mark said the
ruthless criticism of all that exists
it's where you get things like critical
theory and critical race theory and so
either way you respond in those in that
system
you actually advance the purpose of
political correctness
all right you gave me a lot there so
first you're talking about sort of
freedom from
versus freedom two that's your that's
your heroine
guy argument um
have conservatives then just failed i
mean is this just like a
failing of you nice conservatives that
now i talk to
who are seemingly very friendly and not
nearly as scary as i was
told yes we failed we failed
conservatives
totally failed on this because
what the left is offering a vision of
society
it's basically the left the radical
left's vision of society is just
the the inverse of whatever the vision
used to be you know in the 1950s if you
were a communist you would be canceled
you would lose your career in hollywood
you could be prosecuted i mean it was it
was illegal under the smith act
uh today you'll be canceled if you're an
anti-communist right so it's just you'll
still be canceled but it's just
the total flip of it but they're
actually putting forward that vision of
society
what is the conservative vision on this
the conservative vision is to defend now
and this is only over the last 20 years
or so
to defend free speech in the abstract
right or to defend freedom of belief in
the abstinence always in the abstract
but they won't ever get down to the
brass tacks of
what should we say what do we believe
what is our
what are we offering people other than
nothing and it's this is why on the
occasions that republicans have won
elections in in the last 20 years
all we've ever managed to do almost
without exception
is cut taxes a little bit and maybe cut
regulation a little bit but actually
maybe not
and that's it and and so the i guess the
question you have to ask yourself is
after
after the reagan revolution and even the
trump revolution and the gingrich
revolution we want to won all these
elections
would you say the country today is more
conservative
more free than it was 20 years ago
no way what do you think about this nols
i think you're making the argument
of our anarchist friend michael malus
who always says that conservatism
is liberalism at the speed limit yes
now i i think that's a great observation
i would disagree with our friend michael
mallis
uh in that he is are you guys friends i
just included you in the friend thing i
don't know i just
i i have been a great admirer of michael
ever since he has one of the greatest
book titles of all time
dear reader yeah his book his book uh
citing uh
the leader of north korea uh really
great very politically incorrect you
probably couldn't do it these days
but my answer to this and i think this
is where
a conservative would depart from an
anarchist is
the the anarchist is sort of you know
get off my law and let's dissolve all
these sorts of bonds
and i just think that that is a utopian
political vision
it's the flip side of the coin to
socialism right these are these are both
atomizing
visions of society that have a what i
would call a false anthropology a false
understanding of human nature
a false understanding of how society
works we're not born
into the world as free-floating atoms
totally unbound
we're not born totally with entitlement
and only with rights
we're also born into a real family the
bedrock political unit
in a real community in a real state in a
real country
and we have not only rights but
obligations to those things
and we have not only freedoms but
responsibilities
to use those freedoms carefully and
the civilization and the society as a
whole has the right
to put certain limits on there and not
only the right to do that
but i think the responsibility so is
that really
the main takeaway in some ways of the
book that that standards and just having
some limits really yeah is basically
the key to the whole thing that that
we're now at the point where we've
degraded it all to the point
where we have drag queen story hour and
as i've told you
no gay person that i know is happy about
drag queen story hour
if anything they're more annoyed than
say a traditional conservative like
yourself
because it makes gay people look bad you
know it gives you a bad name right
so but it but once you remove any level
of standard it's like
like now i mean we've talked about this
now i'm at the point where i'm like
there is
nothing too crazy i every morning i wake
up i look at twitter drag queen story
hour
you know cartoon network trans this you
know
nickelodeon just the whole thing where
it's like there's nothing that could
surprise me at this point because there
are no standards anymore
right there there are no standards and
it cuts at the heart of self-government
because
what the argument being made by the
liberals
and by libertarians and a great many
conservatives
is well michael if you
enforce some standard well look that's
just your opinion man
that's just your preference and your
value and look uh
as one of the squishes on the right he's
no longer really on the right but he
used to be
as he very famously said a
drag queen story hour is one of the
blessings of liberty if we tell
drag queens and radical organizations
that they are not permitted to twerk for
toddlers at the public library or in the
school
why they'll tell us that we can't go to
church on sunday and
the the flaws here are mine i think i
think you're talking about david french
i wanted to be nice and not name him but
well i think in this case i don't like
making about people but it is because i
remember seeing that twitter thread and
i was like
yeah if this is what conservative is
conservatism is then that's not
what i am now i'll tell you that much
yeah and i think you know
david has you know always been nice to
me uh but
i guess the niceness is sort of the
problem isn't it because
the if conservatism means uh
that drag queens can twerk for toddlers
somewhere one has lost the threat
and i think what it also fails to
recognize is one they're already telling
us
to that we can't go to church on sunday
right they told us that for about a year
they left the marijuana shop
open but they shut down the churches so
they're already doing it they're already
telling us that we're not allowed to
practice our religion
in a really public way you saw this
semantic shift from freedom of religion
to freedom of worship right it was a
subtle shift but
political correctness is about subtle
semantic shifts and freedom of worship
is something that
happens in your head right or it happens
some maybe somewhere on a sunday
freedom of religion is different right
and it makes certain claims of the world
but so one i think as a practical matter
their argument is just ridiculous
but but moreover at the heart of that
argument is this assertion
that we can just never know any anything
about
morality or philosophy or the way things
are supposed to be that we can just we
can't know it's all just preferences
but the thing about self-government is
you've got to know you've the whole
point of self-government is that we
persuading one another having debate
having discussion
using our speech we will persuade one
another of how we want to live and we
will make
certain moral conclusions i know it's
very popular these days to say
you can't legislate morality that is a
meaningless statement
all laws legislate morality any law on
murder
any law on the the death penalty any law
and a parking ticket for goodness sakes
is making moral claims it's referring to
the moral law so if we if we can't
actually know stuff
if we can't rely on our faculties of
reason and our our conscience
which now are being explicitly denied by
the radical left right they're saying
that
that you're the idea that you have
objective uh truth or you know faculties
of reason is somehow bigoted or
white supremacist but if you don't have
that then you
you can't govern yourselves right you
can't reason through these things and
it's it's what's led to
the fouchus of the world it's what's led
to this bureaucratic state that's just
going to make decisions for us
because we no longer have the right to
or the ability to discuss them do you
think there's also
a misunderstanding of how they're
playing the game
by people let's say on our side in that
when when someone like french says well
if we don't give them drag queen story
hour then they're not going to give us
freedom to worship or something like
that
that what i think he's really
fundamentally misunderstanding is they
don't want to give you anything no
matter what
you can you can give them drag queen
story hour and then the next crazier
thing and then the next crazier thing
but that's not i think he they sort of
think like oh it's giving them enough
penance to so they'll be nice to us
but it never turns out that way yeah
they're they they are
fun the the sort of squishy side of this
argument is is fundamentally
misunderstanding
the nature of our political opponents
who truly don't care they don't care
about how nice and genteel we are they
actually see that as a weakness
but they also misunderstand
everything they also misunderstand the
history of conservatism and conservative
thought as well as the history of the
united states
now we are told that really what
conservatives need to stand for i'll use
the university for
an example is we need to stand for
academic freedom
and you can teach anything you want and
if you
object to the radical critical theorists
in the classroom
then you are threatening our sacred
principle of academic freedom
william f buckley jr founder of the the
modern conservative movement
he founder of national review right he
he launched his career and the
conservative movement
with a book called god and man at yale
everyone remembers that
subtitle the superstitions of academic
freedom
he refers in that book to academic
freedom as a hoax
it's a farce it's not it only cuts in
one direction and buckley makes this
point he says
the yale department of sociology would
never hire someone
who gave lectures on the biological
superiority of the aryan
they would never hire a neo-nazi nor
should they they they have a standard
they have an understanding of the world
and they have a responsibility to
fulfill their mission as
educators now the
many of the people who claim the legacy
of william f buckley jr
love this idea of academic freedom but
it remains a hoax it's a farce it it
only ever goes
in one direction so is this where when
you see that you know some of the states
uh in many cases led by chris ruffo who
i've had on the show have you have you
talked to chris
yes he's doing great work doing
incredible like he's not just talking
he's doing
when you see these states taking actions
to keep critical race there out of the
schools
this is an application of state power
you're okay with obviously
of course because it's it's necessary
when when i say
that we we need to have standards i'm
not just saying you know come on guys
you've got to i'm saying
inevitably we will have standards
inevitably
inevitably the state will have something
to say about education
they run the education system and let's
say it's even a private school
inevitably someone is going to set
the curriculum there's a very popular
expression these days they'll say
a lot of conservatives say it we don't
want to teach students
what to think only how to think and you
say okay
good i'm with you except in order to
know how to think
you need to know what to think in order
for me to know how to think about
mathematics i need to know that two plus
two equals four
and that's that is a coercive exercise
the t when the teacher
tells the student that if the student
says no actually two plus two equals
five
the student will get a bad grade they
will be punished for that because you
need to know those facts and it's true
not just in mathematics
it's true in history it's true in
philosophy it's true in ethics so
education is always going to be in a
coercive exercise
sometimes you'll hear now same kind of
people will say
we we should educate students not
indoctrinate them
the words are synonyms they mean the
exact same thing they're just
but one has a negative connotation one
has a positive connotation
and so when i say that we need standards
when i say that we need
just and prudent censorship i'm not
saying this is an arbitrary exercise of
will
or it's just a way to own the libs and
punish our enemies i mean that's all
well and good
but i'm saying we need to using our
faculties of reason not doing anything
immoral following standards of justice
and truth we need to express those
things and tell people now actually some
things are true and some things are
false what i'm saying is that
in order to save free speech we must
embrace
censorship which is inevitable and i
don't want the crazy radical left
censorship
that's not going to let me say true
things but we need to recognize there
must be some guard rails here because
otherwise you're not going to have free
speech at all
do you remember knowles a few years back
when we first started doing shows
together and i said to you
i will become the furthest right of all
of you people
you people that's what i was calling you
conservatives at the time and i was
talking about i was sitting in a room
with you and clavin and
shapiro and everything else because i
know what this thing is i was in it
and and that's why i think you're so
interesting at the moment because we've
really
sort of met somewhere here that i think
represents what the future of the right
will be
you go into the book you you also talk a
bit about religion and atheism
and you talk about john locke and his
feelings towards atheism
and uh i'm i'm with you there too
this this secular this purely secular
thing that we seem to be doing at the
moment
it ain't working huh well this this is
such an important point here because
what what i'm gonna hear
i i know that i'm already hearing this
in the book the big criticism is
that i am pushing an illiberal
authoritarian theocratic view of the
word i don't know where they got that
from but it's in there that's what they
say i like this with the theocratic
this that's the theocratic i know i wag
my finger
the fact is that john locke the father
of liberalism
has a much more restrictive view of
speech than i do
okay in in john locke's letter
concerning toleration
letter concerning toleration he says you
know we got to tolerate people that's
really good
except for atheists atheists cannot they
cannot be tolerated because they
undercut the entire
vision we have of society john milton
who wrote
probably the most famous defense of free
speech in the english language it's
called areopagitica
he defends the free speech in the free
press and everyone has to have free
speech
except for catholics and i and i by the
way i see his argument he's saying that
these years of political strife and
turmoil if you
uh allow these tensions to really fester
the whole society is going to fall apart
it very nearly did in john milton's
lifetime and so he's saying there have
to be some limits
to things that we all agree on for the
very purpose of having free speech
i'm glad they didn't outlaw well i
suppose they did but i'm glad here we
haven't outlawed catholics from speaking
otherwise i wouldn't have been able to
write
this book but obviously there are some
limits here and when you talk about
religion
another one of these very silly sayings
that you hear
on from the left today and from some on
the squishy right is they'll say
we need a firm separation between church
and state this is a secular country
and where did the founding fathers say
that well it's kind of hard to find
actually you don't really see a lot of
examples of it
but we we definitely need that and when
i
say that we need to take religion
seriously in public life
i am not i'm not even saying this as a
normative statement i'm not
it's not a rallying cry necessarily so
much as it is
a descriptive statement i'm just saying
all
political arrangements make religious
claims
you have there's always got to be some
relationship between religion and
politics
because your polity the way you view
your citizens the way you view your laws
those refer to the moral law those refer
to our understanding of human nature of
of what humanity even is which by the
way you're seeing challenge now in the
sort of transgender
ideology because that's that's positing
a vision of human nature that says
that uh one's body has nothing to do
with what who one really is you know i
could
i could look like a man i got the adam's
apple i have the deep voice but if i say
that somehow i'm a woman it's not even
that it's complicated
which is how life really is it's not
even that it's um 50 50 or something
i just am a woman right because that's a
vision of human nature
and that you should just go for it at
that very moment which is even more
disturbing jordan peterson's talked
about that a lot that
you have to still think about all of the
things that are going to change in your
life and guess what
not every eight-year-old can figure that
all out
right of course i mean when we're
talking about the
children it's preposterous we say that
you know i mean first of all we have age
of consent laws for a reason because
because
uh children have not come to understand
their freedom right they have not
had education they they're not capable
of perfect
or even remotely adequate reason so
we're saying okay
if uh if a 17 year old girl sleeps with
her 19 year old boyfriend
that is rape that is illegal in certain
places
that is a very heinous crime but if a
seven-year-old decides to hack off
perfectly functioning organs
and and pump themselves full of
cross-sex hormones
that is not only permissible that is
actually mandatory and if parents don't
let the kids do that
they are going to call child protective
services and have the children taken
away
those two views obviously can't be held
at the same time but it's because of
fundamentally a religious confusion and
an uh inability
to make moral claims in politics so okay
so then let's back up to the atheism
thing for a second because when i was
reading what you had in there with some
of the quotes from john locke this idea
his argument in essence seemed to be
that if if you were to let the atheists
world view flourish
that the amount of destruction would
sort of you just wouldn't be able to
build anything after i'm sort of loosely
loosely doing it there that kind of
feels right to me which is why
the atheist the atheist movement that
was really powerful
online say five years ago or seven years
ago has been completely obliterated and
i don't know one
atheist public atheist that's really
making any sort of political sense i
mean richard dawkins
apologized to the mob because of this
trans thing
and he had no problem standing up to
radical islamists for his whole career
and now he's apologizing
over you know young children
transitioning yes i mean
this the kind of recent movement of
atheists in the 2000s
never made much sense at all but
atheists generally
don't make a lot of sense they can be
perfectly fine lovely people but
it that you don't want to just let's
just be cool i don't want to jail them
but
but it does lead to madness and it's
it's worth pointing out too atheism is a
good example
our country is premised on the idea
that we have certain unalienable natural
rights given to us by god
right by our creator capital c it's
right there in the founding documents of
our country
so if you come in and you not only deny
that that is
true but you actively seek to subvert
that
the country can't tolerate that it that
undermi
all of these wonderful things we've
gotten from our country this broad
defense of speech and all the other
rights and institutions we have
are undermined when you undermine the
very basis of the country there
chesterton has a good line on it he says
there is a thought
that stops thought and that's the only
thought that ought to be stopped it's
it's a good line when you think about
critical race theory right you hear this
all the time
with critical race theory they say we
need to expand the curriculum
when we add these radical racist classes
it's just to expand and open the
curriculum
first of all you can't expand a
curriculum there's only so many weeks in
the semester there are only so many
books you can read
every minute you waste on ibram candy is
a moment that you're not reading
a valuable author but moreover you are
not
enhancing a student's education when you
when you put critical race theory into
schools
you are undermining that student's
education because you are you are
telling students
that there really is no such thing as
objective truth that we really can't
rely on our reason
that the things that are the very basis
of our education
the idea that there's truth and we can
try to find it that that is a fool's
errand so you you
you undercut the whole point of
education which is why
when someone like ron desantis goes in
and says no more critical race theory in
schools
he is actually expanding the potential
for education
not restricting he's also being the
reverse
squishy republican which i think is is
what you're asking
for you mentioned at the top um that you
learned some stuff as you were
going through the book and coming up
with some of these ideas what was
something else that you really learned
while writing because that's the to me
that was the fun part of writing when i
was like oh i
really have to dive in and not just say
these things and understand them at a
service level you really got to get in
there and and
pull out the important stuff i i learned
that a lot of what we have come
to regard as just com and i'm talking on
the right i'm talking among
conservatives a lot of what we've come
to regard
as the the nature of our american regime
and the
kind of nature of the founding and how
we understand ourselves in free speech
is kind of bunk and it was kind of just
uh
they're just bumper stickers from the
last 20 years or so
and i i came to a grudging respect
even for the most vile of the leftist
theorists i'll give a good example
is herbert marcuza herbert mayaban
marcusa he was he was actually mocked in
that um coen brothers movie hail caesar
the villain of that movie so so herbert
marcuzza
was one of the critical theorists one of
the ogs in the frankfurt school
and he developed a lot of these
ideologies in a
in the marxist tradition in the western
marxist tradition
thinking specifically about culture and
then he pops up again
he goes and he works for the precursor
to the cia for a while he goes into the
academy for a while
then he pops up again in the 60s as the
father of the new left i mean he's
considered
maybe the most influential figure during
the radical movements of the 60s
and marcus writes one of the most
infamous essays on free speech
ever composed it was called repressive
tolerance
repres seems like a contradiction in
terms and marcus says
he's got a lot of like silly jargon that
you can kind of ignore then he comes to
the heart of it he says
a liberating tolerance would not
tolerate intolerance which he defines as
conservative thought and he and he
observes that the conservatives had
cultural hegemony they had sort of
control over the institutions
they control over the common sense and
so what we need to do to correct that
is censor and suppress the conservatives
and advance the radical leftist thought
and he was decried by people certainly
people on the right and and people on
the left
as well but his his basic point
that you can't tolerate intolerance is
correct that's actually true
yes it is and conservatives need to
learn this
lesson that i i think that the
conservative vision
i think the american vision of free
speech and the way we all live together
is a very tolerant one i think it's the
most tolerant one
basically ever in history but
that is now being undone and it's being
explicitly undone by the radicals the
1619 project
the critical race theorists and the
whole kitten caboodle and by the way
people in elected office i mean even all
the way up to the biden administration
and so that is being undone because we
fail to recognize that marcus
was right there were some things that
are non-negotiable going back to bill
buckley
bill buckley's second book was a defense
of joe mccarthy mccarthyism the
anti-communist crusader
shocking right uh years later i mean
buckley came to temper his his defense
of mccarthy mostly on practical
grounds that mccarthy kind of screwed
things up but i think it was about a
dozen years after that book came out
buckley was talking to a neoconservative
leo chern
and they were debating on his tv show
and sharon said you're for an open
society bill aren't you don't you
we want a big open society
coincidentally the type that's the name
of george soros's philanthropic
foundation
so you can see how this has a leftward
lurch and and bill said
no i don't no i don't think society
should be totally open
i want the society to be considerably
more closed and he used a ridiculous
phrase he said
i'm an epistemological optimist and he
kind of made fun of himself he said what
that means is
i think that some things are settled i
think that some things we don't actually
need to rehash i don't think
that we need to rehash nazism i don't
think we need to rehash communism
and he the point he's making is not just
one of practical politics
he's actually making a point about
knowledge how we know things
certain things you just have to assume
in mathematics
you have to just assume certain axioms a
equals a
a plus b equals b plus a right certain
things that i can't prove
i can't but you have to just assume it i
have to assume
that my faculties of reason are somewhat
reliable
i have to assume it i have to assume
that objective truth exists
i have to assume it because otherwise i
am rendered
speechless what i mean by that is i
can't you can't make an argument
if there is no such thing as objective
truth and if we don't have faculties of
reason so you have to assume those
things
and when people come in and try to
obliterate your belief in those things
you must resist it and you must suppress
that it's so interesting to me because
you're basically making the argument for
why
i can't call myself a liberal with a
straight face anymore
because of the objective truth issue
that you're bringing up and the paradox
of tolerance which is why the
seven remaining liberals that are
flailing around right now
you you you talk about the squishy
republicans or the squishy conservatives
i see them as the the ineffectual
liberals it's like
you you guys let this in you have now
none of the tools to deal with it but
your biggest fear i mean i say this all
the time but your biggest fear is that
you don't want to be called conservative
and it's like yeah they're not coming
for you
and you you've done this thing which is
not permitted anymore in society
which is you've thought about things and
changed your mind on some issues right
and unfortunately forget about the left
they're not changing their mind either
they're
quite successful so why would they but
the right refuses to change its mind i
think
the right had some good ideas and then
they turn those ideas into slogans
and they turn those slogans into bumper
stickers and every bumper sticker is
wrong you can't
reality will not be distilled into a few
pithy little sayings on
a napkin and they they refuse to rethink
it so
the right knows at this point that it's
in a losing strategy right the right
knows that it's just losing ground after
ground doesn't even when we
win elections we lose but they're not
willing to rethink things
look at objective reality with new eyes
and
change their mind so so i see you
flailing your arms or you know you're
probably shaking people by the shoulders
for the for the seven remaining liberals
but one could do the same thing about
the conservatives who who fail to
recognize
that the strategy that they may have
adopted in the best hopes
has not worked because reality was a
little different than that theory and
we've got to rethink
our history we've got to rethink our
philosophy and we've got to
actually try to win again so on that
note
knows let's let's end with this because
i've got a heart out today even though i
could do 20 hours with you obviously
uh what does the future that you're
writing about in that book that i wrote
about in my book that we talk about all
the time
what does it actually look like what
what can we be doing what can we be
messaging
to the people that watch our shows that
get it they don't want to be the broken
liberals
they don't want to be the dis the
squishy republicans
conservatives what what is it that we're
building and and who's going to help us
build it
because that's the whole thing that i'm
always going for now
the future involves the word no
we need to be able to use the word no
only by saying no
will you be able to say yes only by
saying no
to certain destructive ideologies will
you be able to say yes
to edifying to building up again only by
saying
no to critical race theory to radical
gender ideology
to this nihilistic secularism that is
pervading the culture only by saying no
we will not tolerate that in our schools
in our institutions in our workplaces
by saying no we will be able to say
there is such a thing as truth
we can know things not just physical
scientific things but moral things
philosophical things even religious
things we can know that in our politics
and we can build up from there we need
to stop being so damn nice
and we also need to get rid of the
premises that that our adversaries have
foisted on us you know
when when the squishes for the last 20
or 30 years have only focused on
economic issues right you hear this i'm
a fiscal conservative but social liberal
or whatever
they i don't even know what that means
anymore it doesn't mean anything anymore
it doesn't mean
it means you're a conservative who
doesn't want to admit it or because
you're really a guilty liberal or
something like that yeah
yes yeah and it also if you say that all
i care about is economics
you're saying the same thing as the
socialist the socialist
views man as essentially an economic
being
yes it's just it's just like stuff you
know and and the
the squishy conservative is saying the
same thing we need to say something
different
phyllis schlafly one of the great
conservative leaders of the last century
had a very famous saying she said we
need a choice not an
echo and what we've had so far is a left
that is putting forward a vision of
society
and we've had a right that basically
agrees with them
or is unwilling to have the courage to
stand up to them but one does need
courage we need to accept the reality
that there is truth and there is virtue
and we need to recognize that the
prerequisite virtue
is courage it's not enough to lose with
dignity as all the undignified people do
you have to have the courage to make
claims to enforce those claims
and to win knowles
you become pretty good at this i'll give
it to you you've become
pretty good at this you know when when i
said to you well what what
painted forward for us you know what is
it going to look like and he said well
we got to say no
that was your howard beal i'm mad as
hell and i'm not going to take it
anymore speech if you've been in a
jacket
coming out of the rain and screaming and
you're going to rip your microphone off
at the end
i think that's that was it speechless
is out right now it's in your hand and
although i am not on the back cover i am
in the beginning and
you are there that's just enough first
first pages
dave rubin saying very nice things about
me i don't if you never do it again i've
got the proof it's right here
knowles you're invited to my birthday
party in crazy la in a couple weeks i
hope you i hope you're willing to leave
nashville
but i get it i get it you want your
fried bologna
and your boots and your guitar
dave there is one thing that could get
me to go back to that failed state
that is your birthday but that's the one
thing and i'll only stay for the party
that i'm going i'm flying back out
afterwards
good work girls see you soon if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell